foreign
book in history no volume ever written
has been more loved and quoted and its
words sometimes simple and sometimes
mysterious should always be studied
carefully it is the Bible the word of
God welcome to Bible answers live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Jean
Ross Hello friends Pastor Doug is out
this evening but how about an amazing
fact a astonishing and awe-inspiring a
dog's sense of smell is so remarkable
that they can detect sins at
concentrations as low as parts per
trillion making their sense of smell
tens of thousands of times more
sensitive than ours to put this into
perspective a dog for example walking
into a kitchen hours after a meal was
cooked He's Able if he chooses to
distinguish the individual ingredients
the herbs and even the spices that were
used in the preparation of multiple
dishes
now in the field of search and rescue
dogs play a critical role in locating
missing persons these dogs are able to
detect the faintest traces of human
scent even under the most challenging
environments one incredible instance
occurred during the aftermath of 9 11
attacks in New York City train dogs
tirelessly worked alongside their rescue
teams sniffing through rubble and debris
to locate survivors in one instance a
search and rescue dog named tracker
located a Survivor buried under 30 feet
of debris from the collapsed World Trade
Center
another compelling example of the dog
sense of smell involves the world of
medical detection dogs
these canine Marvels have been trained
to detect the saint of specific diseases
including certain types of cancers and
diabetes trained dogs are able to
identify certain cancers in patients by
simply sniffing their breath or a mole
on their skin
a dog sense of smell is capable of feeds
that defy our understanding from
locating survivors in disaster zones to
detecting diseases with astonishing
accuracy the dog sense of smell serves
as a constant reminder of the marvels of
a compassionate Creator God
the Bible tells us in Romans chapter 1
verse 20 speaking of the marvels of
God's creation for since the creation of
the world his invisible attributes have
been clearly seen being understood by
the things that were made even his
eternal power and godded so that they
are without excuse
you know Carlos in the world around us
just the things that God has made we can
see God's hand we stand in awe when we
see what animals can do you think of sea
turtles that are able to travel
thousands of miles from where they were
born and then come back to the very same
Beach to the eggs all of the marvels of
creation testify to us of a caring
loving Creator amen amen and that makes
me think of the new heavens and the new
Earth when we'll have all our senses in
height enlightened that's right I
imagine what we'll be able to do too
absolutely
well friends if you'd like to learn more
about the marvels of God's creation
we've got a free book that we would like
to give you one of the amazing facts
books it's called wonders of creation
and how do people get that book well
they can call
1-800-835-6747 or they can dial pound
250 and when you pound when you dial
pound 250 you say Bible answers live and
you'll be able to also get a copy it's
free shipping in the USA USA and Canada
territories only
and so we also want to greet those that
are tuning in on kdia and San Francisco
live and radio Jubilee in Tustin
California down in Southern California
absolutely want to welcome those who are
joining us not only listening on various
land-based uh radio stations but also on
satellite radio station and those
watching online and on AF TV and if you
have a Bible question our phone line
here to the studio is
800-463-7297 that's
800-463-7297 that's with your Bible
question and the other phone line that
Pastor Carlos mentioned if you have a uh
the free offer that we talk about that's
800-835-6747 well we have some callers
on standby ready to go why don't you
start with prayer and then we'll go to
the four lines let's pray father thank
you for another beautiful day of life
and this opportunity to spend time in
your word we just ask that your spirit
guide us so that we can found everything
on it as it is written and that those
that are listening and joining us maybe
rejoice in learning more as we draw
closer to you and we ask this in Jesus
name amen amen all right so if we have
Debbie from Canada welcome to Bible
answers live Debbie you're on the air
doing well thank you
okay I have a question I'm in the
YouTube chat
um and we were talking about Moses last
week in the chat and I wanted to know
did God bury Moses or did he go straight
to heaven
and in Jude 1 9 when it says Michael the
Archangel
we want to know if that's Jesus
sure we'll we'll take it in two parts
first of all I did was Moses buried well
the Bible says he was it says he died
and God buried him and then when you go
to Jude and you read that story it talks
about Michael the Archangel and the
devil disputing over the body of Moses
now the Bible doesn't say how long Moses
was buried
um it is interesting though you know he
serves as a type of Christ he led the
children of Israel out of bondage he
brought them to the promised land in one
way as a type Moses symbolizes Christ
Jesus is our deliverer he delivers us
from sin and Jesus died he was buried
but then he rose and he ascended to
Heaven a minute should there be seen the
experience of Moses so the Bible doesn't
say maybe it was three days who knows
three three nights but um
Jude where it talks about Michael the
Archangel yes we believe that Michael is
one of the prophetic names that we find
both in Revelation and Daniel with
reference to Jesus we also find that in
Jude we're not saying Jesus is an angel
the word Archangel simply means the
ruler of the Angels or the one above the
Angels some translators put it as the
commander of the Angelic host or the
commander of the Angels so when we talk
about Michael we're not saying that
Christ is an Angel by any means he's the
ruler of the Angels now there's a couple
of ways we can we can help to identify
this the Bible says that when Jesus
comes he will have the voice of the
Archangel and the voice of the Archangel
will raise the dead Jesus said speaking
of his second coming they shall hear the
voice of the son of man and shall come
forth so if Christ has the voice that
raises the dead and according to Paul in
Thessalonians is the voice of the
Archangel that raises the dead then you
just put two and two together Michael
then is the prophetic name of Jesus and
the word Michael means who is like God
so there's a number of parallel else
there we actually have a book called
Michael the Archangel and we'll be happy
to send this to anyone who calls and
asks what's that number Carlos yes that
number is
1-800-835-6747 or if you're on your
mobile device you can dial pound 250 and
say Bible answers live and you can
request it there okay very good thank
you Debbie for your call next we have
Jerry from Colorado Jerry you're live on
the air
hey thanks guys for answering my
questions I just want to address
something that you said at the very
beginning but there's a book out there
called story of redemption and on
chapter three it gives a special glimpse
of Eden
my question tonight is
when the ark was restored to Jerusalem
after it spent a time after that
gentleman's house after been taken back
from the Philistines was that an intent
and was it an original Sanctuary tent
and did they have Sanctuary Services
morning and evening that talks about
that in first Chronicles 16. okay good
question let's give a little bit of the
background for those who might be
joining us so when the children of
Israel took possession of the promised
land
um the place where the Tabernacle was
placed which was the tent where of
course you had the holy and the most
holy place in the outer Courtyard I was
in a place called Shiloh at first and um
it was there that the temple was kept
before it was moved at the time of
Solomon into actually the the the temple
meaning the the Tabernacle the taint was
moved during the time of David but the
actual building was built during the
time of Solomon
um the Ark of the Covenant was taken by
the Philistines for a period of time and
came back to Israel and was placed back
there at Shiloh where it was they did
offer the services the morning and the
evening sacrifices as had been given
during their Wilderness wanderings even
during the time of the The Exodus coming
up from Jerusalem the Levites were in
charge of taking care of the different
things associated with the temple it was
also during this time that you read
about Samuel the prophet who was also a
Levi and also served in the temple
around that time period so it was there
until David then was transferred to
Jerusalem and then during the time of
King Solomon it was actually placed in
the temple that was actually built of
stone amen
all right who do we have next next we
have Gary from Illinois welcome to Bible
answers live you're on the air
thank you
we're seeing major climate events
happening Canadian wildfires size of
Ohio European heat waves you know and
fire water temperatures above 100
degrees around the Florida Keys where uh
where you know coral reefs are at and so
these are the signs that Jesus says in
Matthew 24 when you see these signs you
know that time is near but at the same
time I'm seeing diversions you know
Congressional hearings on UFOs where
they got bodies they got spacecrafts and
and reporters interviewing AI you know
about their intentions towards humanity
and so my question is you know yes we
need to be we need to keep our uh
ourselves focused on the signs that
Jesus is talking about but do you think
these diversions are you know a
coincidence or do you think we're going
to see regular you know diversions
that'll draw us away from these
important signs we see in Matthew 24
about you know plagues and pestilence
wars and rumors Wars you know yeah let
me add to that good question you know
first of all the devil is going to try
and deceive the Bible says that before
Jesus comes the devil will deceive if
possible let's see Matthew 24 even the
very elect now that doesn't mean he's
going to deceive the elect but his
deceptions are going to be so powerful
so well crafted that he'll try and
deceive
anyone and everyone so there's going to
be some deception for just about every
person out there that doesn't know the
truth of God's word whether it's going
to be so-called alien visitations from
space or whether it's other conspiracy
theories that might arise or maybe
advances with AI or whatever whatever it
might be the devil is going to try to
use it to deceive people in the last
days now we do know that a changing
world the Bible does speak of
earthquakes talks of natural disasters
and calamities Talks Of War and rumors
of wars all of these things Jesus gives
in Matthew 24 as signs of the coming of
Christ but I think one of the most
significant signs is he says as it was
in the days of Noah so it'll also be
before the son of man comes and he says
as it was in the days of Sodom Gomorrah
so it'll be before Jesus comes we see
the moral decay in society and I think
that's one of the clearest evidences
that we are living close to the end of
time we've been bombarded in just the
last decade or so with some of the
strangest social ideas of what is
marriage or what is a man or what is a
woman or what constitutes a family that
you know people prior to that probably
would have never even entertained so we
can see just in the moral fabric of
society things are just falling apart
and yes Jesus does need to come and I
think the devil's going to use
everything he can to try and deceive but
we don't have to be deceived as the
Bible says if you know the truth the
truth will set you free and that's where
our hope needs to be amen and that I was
just going to say that also I think that
we're not gonna we know these things
we're not gonna be focused on them our
focus is going to be on wanting to draw
closer to God wanting to do God's will
wanting to reach others so even though
we're aware of these things our focus is
not on those things per se but our focus
is going to be on on uplifting and
serving God and as as best we can
absolutely you know we have a study
guide Pastor Carlos that talks about the
second coming of Christ and it's called
ultimate deliverance and that is really
what the world needs that's going to be
the ultimate solution to the problems
that we have here on this Earth we'll be
happy to send this to anyone who calls
and asks just call and ask for that
study guide It's called ultimate
Deliverance we'll be happy to send it to
anyone here in North America if you're
outside of North America just go to the
website just amazingfacts.org and what's
the number to call offer is
1-800-835-6747 or mobile devices dial
pound 250 and say Bible answers live and
you'll be able to order that
all right all right next we have Patty
from Oregon Patty welcome to Bible
answers live
a lot of people are
ordained pastors okay all right good
question well you know of course what we
want to do especially when it comes to
this program is we want to ask well what
does the Bible say and does the bible
give us an example of a woman that
served in the capacity of an apostle or
as a priest and to be honest just with
the word with the Bible both in the Old
Testament in the New Testament we don't
find women serving in those roles as a
priest or as an apostle now what we do
find which is very interesting both in
the Old Testament and in New Testament
we do find examples of women that served
in the role of a prophet a prophetess we
find that in the Old Testament Deborah
we also find the New Testament so God
has chosen different roles and different
responsibilities for people to serve
that doesn't mean to say that a woman
can serve in Ministry matter of fact
they need to serve everybody needs to be
involved in Ministry there are different
areas of ministry different
responsibilities that God has given but
when it comes to pastoral Ministry or
the role of an elder if you look at the
description that's given in the Bible
that's something that God has chosen to
really place on the shoulders of the man
as the leader in the home as the leader
in the church that's the role that God
has given so there's a Biblical glance
you know we do have a book called woman
in Ministry and we'll be happy to send
it to anyone who calls and asks if you'd
like to study more about this uh the
number for that is
800-835-6747 and you can just call and
ask for that book written by Pastor Doug
it's called woman in Ministry amen
next we have Judith Judith from Nevada
Judith welcome you are on the air
hello hey
this is
we can hear you yes
yes yes Pastor I I have a question on uh
related to Isaiah Chapter 14 verse 13
where God meets with the angels of the
uttermost side of the noise uh just this
is a mystery for me to understand is
this where doxology happens or or at the
same time also when our Guardian Angel
winged their way to the high priest
Jesus to reveal our prayers can you tell
us the biblical perspective of the
congregation of the north thank you are
you wondering about that specific phrase
there in verse 13 says on the farthest
sides of the north where Lucifer wanted
to have his throne okay good question
let me read the whole verse for those
who might not have their Bible in front
of them Isaiah Chapter 14 verse 13 and
this is really talking about this
rebellious Angel called lucifan and what
brought about his Rebellion against God
it says for you have said in your heart
I will Ascend you to heaven I'll exalt
my throne above the stars of God I will
also sit on the mount on the
congregation on the farther sides of the
North
verse 14 I will Ascend above the heights
of the clouds I will be like the most
high so this is Lucifer there in heaven
and this brought about this war you read
about in Revelation chapter 12. now what
did it mean when he says on the father's
sides of the north I will sit on the
Mount of the congregation uh the
father's side of the north it's
interesting there is a historical
application you read about this in
Ezekiel 28 verse 16 the father's side of
the north was a reference to Mount Zion
Mount Zion upon which Jerusalem was
built and more specifically the temple
was built
serves as a type of the Heavenly throne
room or where the Heavenly Temple is you
find the Bible talking about a Heavenly
temple being built in Hebrews and so the
devil wanted a position in the very
presence he wanted to take the Throne of
God he wanted to be in the temple in the
most holy Place talk about the size of
the North Mount Zion he wanted to
actually receive the worship of the
angels and this brought about this
Rebellion that we read about in
Revelation 12.
yeah Psalms 48 verses 1 and 2 clearly
shows that sides of the north is Mount
Zion it's Mount Zion yep absolutely good
if we do have a study guide that talks
about the origin of evil and it's called
did God create a devil where did the
devil come from yeah we'll be happy to
send it to anyone who calls and asks
1-800-835-6747 or dial pound 250 and ask
for Bible answers live next we have
Jeffrey from Washington Jeffrey welcome
to Bible answers live
oh
good evening Pastor John Pastor Carlos
thank you for taking my call
you're welcome thanks for calling
Jeffrey
I see in the Bible that it's fairly
clear to me that God is on trial
mentioned in Revelation at least and
um
Satan is doing the accusing from what I
understand and I hear people say that
one of Satan's claims or accusations is
that it is impossible for humans to obey
God or God's law
um do you see anywhere in the Bible that
suggests that Satan is making that
accusation I'm hoping that you guys can
help Okay
um you know one of the accusations that
Satan makes against God is that you know
God is not fair God says he's a god of
love and if he's a god of love why does
he require us to keep his Ten
Commandments
and uh you know probably you won't find
anywhere in the Bible where it says the
say the devil is saying we can't keep
God's Commandments however unfortunate
it is uh there are many Christians that
say that we can't really keep God's
Commandments but if you look at what the
Bible says the Bible is very clear that
by the power of Christ the Holy Spirit
dwelling within us we can keep his
Commandments matter of fact Revelation
chapter 12 verse 17 describes God's
people in the last days and says these
are the ones who keep the Commandments
of God and they have the testimony of
Jesus Revelation 14 12 says they also
have the faith of Jesus so when we have
the faith of Jesus we're going to be
able to keep the commandments of Jesus
why because his law is written within
our heart and and that's the key an
external obedience to the Commandments
based upon our strength is an
impossibility because Jesus said without
me you can do nothing but with him he
said all things are possible so there's
no doubt that with the Holy Spirit work
within us if we are trusting in Him day
by day we can do those things that
humanly speaking on our own trusting in
our own strength we cannot do are they
examples of people in the Bible that
kept God's Commandments absolutely
you've got examples of Shadrach Meshach
and Abednego on the plane of dura who
refuse to Bow Down and Worship the
golden image because it was a violation
one of The Commandments
you got Daniel that went into the lion's
den because he refused to violate God's
Commandments he's got Joseph you've got
Esther you've got many other examples in
the Bible and even in New Testament
times people who are willing to lay down
their life rather than violate one of
God's commandments so there's plenty of
examples in scripture and also just the
power of God working in the life of a
person yeah I think it's inferred what
he's asking and you mentioned Revelation
12 it says in Revelation 12 10 that the
devil is accusing us day and night the
accuser of the Brethren and then it says
in 11 but they overcame him where the
blood of the Lamb so I think that it
could be inferred because then you
mentioned reverse 17 where it says and
there they are right they're living in
harmony with God's law they're keeping
his Commandments yeah absolutely we do
have a study guide that talks about the
ten commandments and again the point
about the Ten Commandments if it's just
an external list of do's and don'ts it's
not going to help us but if it's our
desire to keep the law of God because we
trust him we love him we have faith in
him he's always written within our
hearts that it's the New Covenant
promise we have a study guide called
written in stone and it's about the Ten
Commandments but more importantly how
can we apply the Ten Commandments in a
living vibrant way in our life amen amen
we have Emily welcome to Bible answers
live you're on the air
hello
um so my question is where exactly were
the Fallen Angels cast to when they were
cast out of heaven
the verses I'm looking at are second
Peter 2 4 and Revelation 12 9 where
Peter seems to say that they were cast
to Tartarus or the abyss and then
Revelation says they were cast of the
Earth okay good question so you know we
go back to Revelation chapter 12 I think
he's one of the clearest passages that
talk about this rebellion in heaven says
there was war in heaven Michael and
these angels fought against the dragon
and the dragon and these angels fought
and then it tells us the dragon is Satan
and then it says place was found no
longer for them in heaven and they were
cast out of heaven so it appears from
the context in Revelation chapter 12
that this war in heaven occurred
sometime before the creation of Earth
this Rebellion took place a third of the
Angels joined Lucifer became the devil
in his Rebellion against God and the
reason we know a third did because it
says the devil was able to sweep a third
of the stars of Heaven A star symbolize
Angels so a third of the Angels joined
his Rebellion they were cast out of
heaven and appears for a period of time
they kind of wandered through the
universe trying to locate a place where
they could establish their Kingdom right
around this time God goes about creating
the Earth
and he warns Adam and Eve because
there's the tree of the knowledge of
Good and Evil so evil already existed he
warned them about this this evil being
and um you know the story how he evade
of the fruit okay well she took it eight
gave to Adam and well then the devil
claims the Earth Is His and the Earth
from then on served as sort of the
headquarters of the devil's Dominion his
kingdom here on the earth Jesus seems to
endorse this when he speaks of the devil
as being the prince of this Earth
but when Jesus died no longer is the
devil now the representative of Earth
but Christ is the second Adam he took
the place of the first Adam who fell he
now is the second Adam and ultimately
the Earth is going to be restored and
redeemed after the 1000 years
and the devil and centers honor more God
creates a new heavens and a new Earth so
when it says here in second Peter
chapter 2 verse 14 or yeah verse 4
rather that the devil and his angels uh
cast them down to hell it's just a dark
abbess it's not a burning place of
Torment it's the same type of idea of
the bottomless pit that you read about
in Revelation chapter 20. it's an
emptiness it's a darkness that we're
looking for a place that kind of
establish as their own and eventually
the Earth became that place because of
sun yeah and in Revelation 12 it does as
you mentioned they did come here to
Earth which is where they were able to
he's able to put a foothold that's right
but Christ took it away from him that's
right that's why one of The Temptations
that came to Jesus was the devil said if
you bow down worship me I'll give you
the kingdoms of this earth now we might
think well why was that a Temptation
well because the devil claimed them as
his and he was saying to Jesus instead
of having to go through the cross I'll
just give it to you now because that was
the Temptation that came to Christ good
question thank you Emily next we have me
from Texas welcome Jimmy you're alive
yes sir can you hear me yes
okay my question is I'm gonna there's a
pastor once told me this before I left
his church because he was making way too
many predictions
that weren't exactly coming true at all
but but my question is this he told me
that also one of the signs of that a
person hasn't committed the imparnable
sin is they have a desire to serve God
is this true or is this false
no I think it's true you know I think if
there is an Earnest desire that's
evidence that the holy spirit is
convicting and speaking to the heart now
um you know remorse is not necessarily
evidence of the Holy Spirit speaking
because even Judas felt remorse after he
betrayed Christ and he threw the money
down to the templates that I betrayed
innocent blood but then he went out and
he hung himself he was lost but Peter on
the other hand when he realized what he
had done he wept bitterly and he was
forgiven so when the Holy Spirit is
convicting us and we are following that
conviction if we are turning to God in
Repentance that's evidence the holy
spirit is working on us if there is a
turning away from truth and a hardening
of our heart and we don't want to do
those things or are we turning away from
or rejecting the promptings of the Holy
Spirit that's Dangerous Ground we don't
want to be on that ground for long there
does come a point where if we reject the
Holy Spirit the Holy Spirit withdraws
his convicting power and it's the
goodness of God that leads us to
repentance the Bible says so without
that convict acting Spirit
we can't reach that point of repentance
so the Bible says repaint you know when
you hear that voice today is the day of
your salvation don't wait in another day
for stronger impulses or stronger
feelings today if you hear the Holy
Spirit respond friends the program's not
over we're just going to take our mid
program break and we'll be back in just
a few moments with more of your Bible
questions
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
go into all the world and preach the
gospel to Every Creature through radio
television print Evangelistic events and
the internet amazing facts International
is heeding the call of Jesus to go into
all the world millions of individuals
and over 150 countries have been blessed
by the word of God amazing facts have
spawned new spheres of influence in
India Africa China and Indonesia with
each new country come hundreds of
translated booklets study guides and
video presentations produced in each
region for the people of that region
armed with these precious truths gospel
workers are empowered to spread bright
rays of light on every path they travel
please visit
reachtheworld.amazingfacts.org to learn
more about amazing facts International
and how you can participate in this
exciting soul-winning Ministry that
website again is reach the
world.amazingfacts.org thank you for
your support
[Music]
a beast a dragon and a woman they sound
like characters in a fairy tale but that
couldn't be further from the truth these
three symbolic end time powers are
actually found in the Book of Revelation
whose predictions about the soon-coming
crises on Earth aren't a bedtime story
the dragon and the woman is a daring yet
concise overview of the Bible's most
compelling and perplexing end time
players and the struggle between truth
and error
you'll even find out the part America
plays in these last days
if you want to be ready for the
earth-shaking events Yet to Come secure
your copy of the Beast the dragon and
the woman today don't be caught
unprepared for the final events of Bible
prophecy to order your copy of the Beast
the dragon and the woman call
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7 pm
and 8 PM Pacific time to receive any of
the Bible resources mentioned in this
evening's program call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now let's rejoin our hosts
for more Bible answers live
Hello friends and welcome back to Bible
answers live we want to welcome those
who are tuning in if you've never been a
part of this program before this is a
live interactive International Bible
study and if you have a Bible related
question or a question related about
living the Christian Life we'd love to
hear from you this evening our phone
line here to the studio is
800-463-7297 it's
800-463-7297 Pastor Doug batchley's out
this evening but I am Pastor John Ross
and working the phones with me is Pastor
Carlos that's right thank you Carlos
amen who's our next caller we have
Michael from Alabama welcome Michael
you're alive on the air
good evening good evening thank you
tremendously for accepting my call this
is a question I'm trying to ask you for
the past two weeks now because I have
um evidences for my a lot of evidences
for my doubt I'll uh take them one at a
time over separate weeks to make them
more concise basically it's I have a
tremendous problem with broad sweeping
generalizations in the English language
in general and one of these
um it really ticks me off when
professing Christians use this is the
term word of God the Bible is the only
word the Bible is infallible and perfect
here's my the person I don't doubt the
Holy Spirit absolutely being behind the
inspiration to the scriptural writers so
Michael let me let me Mike let me ask
you are you asking um is it wrong to say
the infallible word of God or the word
of God is that your question
what I'm saying is
sound like uh they're putting the guilt
trip on to well-meaning uh uh Christian
lay persons who are still trying to find
out and still I won't say doubting but
especially the way televangelists and
also Protestant fundamentalists have
misused specific verses okay just to
clarify your question so you're saying
um we need to be careful with the way we
use the phrase the word of God because
maybe others don't believe the Bible is
the word of God
oh
um certainly people in other world
religions don't I believe that it is
inspired by the Holy Spirit but here's
the first example
um what if
um the Apocrypha why it now this is
going to be a History Channel type
question why aren't the Apocrypha and
the Dead Sea Scrolls and books that were
excluded by rabbis and priests during
the 400 assignment years from the Old
Testament also some gospels written down
by the remaining apostles who were
themselves what are they called
eyewitness to Christ Jesus why were they
excluded by the early church from the
news
why are those holy writ and I'll take my
answer off here thank you so much for
answering good question what about the
other writings especially the
apocryphalies you mentioned Michael in
particular and there are some other
writings that have come up over the
centuries and for example The Book of
Enoch maybe some of you have heard of
that and why is that not part of the
Bible well when it comes to the Old
Testament the books that made it into
the Old Testament
um you know we're pretty sure on those
books and the Dead Sea Scrolls are
evidence of that not all of the Dead Sea
Scrolls were inspired writings a lot of
it had to do with history during that
inter uh Testament period it had to do
with certain things and and events that
were taking place in Israel but with
reference to the Books of Moses the
books of the Old Testament prophets they
were validated all of the Old Testament
books except for the Book of Esther
there's portions of those books that be
found in the Dead Sea Scrolls when it
comes to New Testament in order to get
your book in the New Testament or
recognized as part of the Bible
there was some very specific tests that
were applied number one you have to be
an eyewitness of Christ the only
exception to that is the Apostle Paul
now the Apostle Paul of course he was
alive at the time of Christ but he
encountered Jesus in a very powerful way
and it was recognized and accepted by
the church that he was called
specifically by Jesus the other Bible
writers were actually eyewitnesses of
events that occurred uh if the evidence
or if the writing could not be validated
that this was a letter that had come
from John or it come from Paul uh They
didn't accept it it had to be a a letter
that was accepted by multi multiple
churches early Christian churches so
those are some of the criteria that were
used it doesn't mean that God doesn't
Inspire other aspects of of writing or
truth but specifically that's the
criteria that was used to make it into
the Bible and we believe all of the
Bible is inspired and also some of those
books their contradictions which is why
they're not they contradict the Bible
then they excluded them as well that's a
good point
we do have a book called The Ultimate
resource yes I was just thinking of that
it's all about the Bible wanting to
learn more about where the Bible came
from and how do we read and study the
Bible just call and ask the number is
800-835-6747 ask for that book called
The Ultimate resource yes so you can
dial pound 250 on your mobile phone and
say Bible answers live
next we have Glenn from Ohio welcome
Glenn to Bible answers live
for good evening from Bethel Ohio
pastors and thank you for taking my call
yes you're welcome Glenn
when Paul wrote a letter to the
Philippians he put in there that every
knee shall bow and every tongue confess
to Jesus is Lord when will that take
place and what would be the method of
confession okay good question well first
of all we know that that's not going to
happen until after the second coming of
Christ let me explain so according to
the Bible we know that things go from
bad to worse until Jesus comes
eventually there is a death sentence
passed prior to the second coming of
Christ the Bible speaks of a great
Showdown that occurs Jesus comes the
second time the wicked are destroyed at
the brightness of his coming
the righteous are resurrected who are
dead and the living are changed in a
moment in the twinkling of an eye and
they are caught up to meet Jesus in the
air the redeemed will then go to heaven
for a thousand years the earth is left
desolate during that one thousand year
period you read about that in Revelation
chapter 20. then at the end of the
Thousand Years Revelation 21 talks about
the New Jerusalem coming down from God
out of Heaven the redeemed come in that
Golden City Christ is there then it is
that all the wicked are resurrected for
what the Bible calls the great white
Throne judgment again this is Revelation
chapter 20. at the end of that judgment
uh just with the evidence that's being
presented every knee will bow and every
tongue will confess that Jesus Christ is
Lord even the wicked even the Devil
Himself will acknowledge that God is
true and that he has done everything he
can to save mankind now this
acknowledgment is not out of genuine
repentance this is just an
acknowledgment of the evidence the
evidence is being presented it's
overwhelming and they say yes it's true
because no sooner do they confess then
it says that the devil is able to
deceive them and they mount the attack
upon the New Jerusalem Revelation
chapter 20 and fire comes down from God
out of heaven and devours them and then
he creates a new heavens and a new Earth
wearing dwells righteousness so it
occurs at the end of their 1000 year
period known as the Millennium and you
read all about it in Revelation chapter
20 and we do have a study guide that
talks about this it's called a thousand
years of peace and for anyone wanting to
learn more about this just call and ask
it's a very interesting study Revelation
20 the number again is
800-835-6747 and after that study guide
It's called a thousand years of peace
all right thank you very much next we
have mark from Oregon Oregon you're live
on the air
hey praise God for the way he works
through you guys uh my question is uh
about the Holy Spirit I have a friend we
speak about the Bible often and I was
just uh his point of view is that the
Holy Spirit has a female quality to it
in the Bible can you help me understand
what the Bible says about that if any
all right
um well when it comes to male and female
the Bible says God created them male and
female and he created them in His image
so there are aspects of the male and
there are aspects of the female as far
as character goes that reflect the
character of God so God is the protector
and you might think of that when you
think of uh The Man He's The Protector
he's the provider for the for the family
you think of the woman you think of the
mother she's the nurturer she's she's
the one that takes care of the needs and
he's sensitive to the needs of of the
family those qualities are both seen in
the Creator the Father the Son and the
Holy Spirit now it's true that the
father Son and Holy Spirit they have
different roles when it comes to the
Plan of Redemption and Jesus is the one
that came to the Earth he gave his life
as a sacrifice for sin he rose from the
dead God the father presides as the
great judge Jesus is also judged and the
Holy Spirit is our intercessor bringing
our prayers before the father and Christ
is also our media DNA intercessor at
high priest so all of them have
different roles in this great work of
judgment but they all share the
qualities of deity they all God they all
have those characteristics that we find
so I wouldn't say that one leans more to
the one-sided characteristics or the
other God is love and you know even even
in the uh well probably in the Christian
World in many different churches people
have the idea of the god of the Old
Testament as being an Angry God a god of
the New Testament Jesus being a more
kind and loving God well Jesus himself
said fear not for the father loves you
so Jesus said he was seeing me has seen
the father if you want to see what God
the father is like look at Jesus amen so
there's no difference between the
qualities of kindness and love and mercy
and Grace that you see manifest in
Christ it's there in the father and it's
also manifest in the work that the Holy
Spirit does in drawing us to Jesus yeah
you know just for that point I had
somebody one time tells me that the Holy
Spirit was a was a female and I said
well that's interesting because in Luke
Chapter Luke chapter one it says that
the Holy Spirit was the one that put the
seed in Mary so how could you be female
never ask me that question again well of
course the Bible also refers to the holy
spirit is when he the comforter comes in
masculine form so yeah transcends right
yep amen all right thank you who's next
next we have uh keris from Washington
welcome to Bible answers live
hello good night um thanks for taking my
calls I'm just asking you guys please if
we could summarize Romans chapter 14
verses 17 to 21. if you guys could
please explain from and thank you yeah
absolutely thank you let me read it says
for the kingdom of God is not eating or
drinking but righteousness peace and the
joy of the holy spirit for he who serves
Christ uh in these things is acceptable
to God and approved by men therefore let
us pursue the things which make for
peace and the things by which one may
edify another do not destroy the work of
God for the sake of food all things
indeed up here but it is evil for men
who eat with the fans it is good neither
to eat meat or drink wine or do anything
by which your brother stumbles or is
offended or made weak
so uh Chris what what's specific about
those verses are you wondering
them of God is not eating and drinking
what does that part really mean okay
okay yeah the point that Paul was
addressing in the early Christian Church
remember they were both uh Jewish
Christians they were also Gentile
Christians and part of the discussion
that occurred had to do with food now it
didn't have to do with where the food
was clean meaning that it was clean meat
so unclean Meats it had to do with food
that was offered or bought at the
marketplace some of which might have
been offered to an idol and Paul says
you know don't ask if it's clean meat
and you're allowed to eat it you know go
ahead and buy it but if you're gonna
offend your brother by doing so then
then don't do that so the point of unity
that Paul is trying to bring it's in the
church between the Gentiles the Jewish
Believers he's bringing them together
and the points of dispute that had to do
with eating and drinking he was trying
to harmonize there were also certain
rituals that were put in place uh
certain Traditions that the Jews had
that certain things couldn't be eaten on
certain days certain things could be
there were certain feasts associated
with the ceremonial law and that became
a point of controversy in the Christian
church and Paul is saying we we don't
want to make these things a point of
controversy he wasn't saying that we can
just eat anything we want because
obviously the Bible tells us Paul tells
us that our bodies are the Temple of the
Holy Spirit and we want to present
ourselves a living holy Sanctuary for
the indwelling of the Holy Spirit but
that was the issue specifically that he
was addressing was the controversy that
was brewing in the early church between
some of the the ceremonial laws as the
Jews applied it and the Gentiles as it
had to do with food and certain
sacrifices and so on yeah I think an
important point is that when Paul or
Peter talk about food they can't be
talking about unclean meat because
that's not food for them that's right
and so that's a very very basic way of
looking at it too it had to do with
certain foods associated with the
ceremonial law exactly absolutely all
right thank you Caris next we have
Daniel from my neck of the woods in
Puerto Rico welcome Daniel
hello good evening thank you for taking
my call
my question is
um I've heard about
um
yesterday I was with somebody and she
started telling me
about the New World Order
I think that's the correct way to say it
in English
um and she was saying some things that
are gonna be in that order like the
money is gonna be
digital now the government is going to
be taking money from us if we don't
behave well and that we can only be
outside of the house for a certain
amount of time
and in my mind I was thinking but I
thought that the Bible said that there
was going to be no more World Government
which in that case How can there be a
new world order
okay yeah the Bible talk about that yeah
it does now the Bible does say that you
know when it talks about end time events
all the world marveled and wandered
after the Beast now doesn't mean that
there's going to be one world government
meaning that we're not going to have
individual countries or individual
states but they will be United in the
last days in the support of the beast
power of Revelation chapter 13. all the
world will be brought under its control
so you'll have different countries
you'll have separate Nations but they
will all support an agenda that'll come
outside of or they'll be United in that
agenda and I'll give you a couple
examples for example we've got movements
now an international movement under the
climate change certain International
laws or requirements that different
nations need to sign on certain
reductions in emission and you know the
story There is almost a governing power
of Nations that is putting pressure on
other countries to go certain ways and
if a country refuses to go along with
certain laws at the End of Time the
Bible says they're not going to be able
to buy and sell so you have economic
sanctions that are going to come into
play at the end of time so you'll still
have your individual countries but
they'll all be working together towards
this common goal at the end yes also
Revelation 17 says that all the kings of
the earth they fornicate or they have
this illicit relationship with Babylon
so yeah Babylon is a symbol of a
religious power yes so you have church
and state working together in this
Alliance at the end of time yeah all
right thank you Daniel
next we have Henry from New York welcome
to Bible answers live Henry
yes
my question is why did why did Israel
get really royalty
okay why did you get rid of royalty you
must be referring to are you talking
about after
um they were conquered by the
Babylonians they never really did have a
king they were always under some other
country they did have certain degrees of
of authority but they were under Babylon
on me to Persia or Greece or Rome and of
course it was Rome that conquered
Jerusalem and the temple in 70 A.D today
Israel is sort of a democratic style
system of government where there is not
a monarchy where they don't have a king
the truth is that Jesus symbolically is
the king the king of the Jews but it's
the king of the whole world and he did
come in fulfillment through the seed of
David and he did take spiritually the
throne and established the kingdom of
Grace and soon at the second coming he
established the kingdom of Glory so
um yeah hopefully that helps Henry yeah
and God never did want a king anyway he
won he was the king he always wanted to
be the king of Israel amen next we have
a Smyrna from California welcome smirna
you're on the air
hi good evening Pastor Ross
plus I do have a question
um it comes actually from one of my
brothers from church we were talking
about Daniel in Revelations book and we
understand that 1260 and the 1290 but
when we were in Daniel 12 11 through 12.
it comes at certain days it's the 13 35
days and when we finish reading that we
were
not understanding where that came from
or what does it mean so my question is
what is that for the 13 35 days what's
the relation good question now this is a
very deep question
um we're finding Daniel chapter 12 a
series of time prophecies that are given
uh you got the 12 60 the 12 90 and the
1335. the key to understanding these
various time prophecies is the starting
point and the starting point has to do
verse 11 it says and at the time the
daily sacrifice are taken away in the
Abomination is set up then it goes on to
the
1290 days
now that all of these different dates
the 1290 the 1260 and the the 1335 all
of the same starting date and that
starting date is 508 and the reason we
say 508 is because in 508 you have the
conversion of clovers King of the Franks
and the whole French nation in essence
became Catholic at that time that was
key in providing the support for the
people power to be fully established in
five
um 38 538 so the 508 date is used as the
starting point for both of that 1290 as
well as the 1335. now the 1290 starting
in 508 brings you to 1798 and the 1335
brings you to 1843.
significance of 1843 is of course the
beginning of the uh enter typical day of
atonement they have any judgment in
Revelation chapter 14 fear God give
glory in the hour of judgment has come
and that's a whole study we don't have
time to get into all the details of that
but Scholars have identified the 1335 as
going from 508 through until 1843. all
right very good next we have trust
trisan from New York you're on Bible
answers live
yes hi Pastor okay so my concern is the
question that I want to ask you is that
um as a question are you allowed to
drink uh occasionally
all right should a Christian drink well
you know the Bible says that in our
times of ignorance God is winged at
there were things that happened back in
Bible times in the Old Testament where
it was not God's ideal will but the
people didn't know any better
for example David had multiple wise
solomitted multiple wise Abraham had
more than one wife but now we know
better now we know it's a sin it's
clearer uh when it comes to drinking
alcohol I think as a Christian we know
we know the consequences of alcohol and
how it's destroyed Families how that
it's got
um it's not healthy it's got you know
issues for the body we know that it's
not the will of God that we as
Christians should drink both by example
and also for our health so should a
Christian drink I would say no I think
you want to set an example you want your
body to be a tabernacle or Temple for
the Holy Spirit you want to be pure you
want to be holy you don't want anything
to defile your body now that doesn't
mean that everyone who drank in the past
are automatically condemned but to those
who know to do right
and don't do it to them it is sin so I
think as Christians today based upon the
evidence that we find in scripture we
don't want to drink any alcohol we want
to be example of faithfulness in all we
do especially when you drink your mind
is not straight you're not thinking
straight and God wants us to be
to be a morally on ground Solid Ground
yeah and the Bible says Pope you just
read the verse he says we don't want to
offend others by what we eat or what we
drink so if we're drinking something
that could be a stumbling block to
somebody else who is a Christian
shouldn't do it you know we do have a
book it's called alcohol and the
Christian and we'll be happy to send
this to you trisan all you have to do is
just call and ask the number is
800-835-6747 ask for the book it's
called alcohol and the Christian we'll
be happy to get in the mail and send it
to you yeah or mobile phones dial number
pound 250 and say Bible answers live
and next we have Celesta from Indiana
welcome you are on the air sister thank
you for taking my call
my question is
if a pig was raised on
grain and healthy food
is it still unsafe to eat that's a good
question Celeste now of course remember
back in Bible times uh pigs were raised
on organic things they you know they ate
pretty healthy back then because they
didn't have all of the chemicals and the
hormones that you have today now of
course it makes it even worse when meat
is pumped full of hormones the Reason
God tells us not to eat pork isn't
because of what the animal ate but it's
because of the biology of the actual
animal itself pigs have an amazing
ability to retain High degrees of toxins
in their flesh in their system pigs can
eat anything is amazing what they can
eat and they don't get sick and they
keep going they are not unhealthy they
have high levels of fat and the first
meat that a doctor will take somebody
off if they're having heart problems is
pork so it's not so much what you feed
the pig it's the biology of the pig
itself that becomes so dangerous because
it does retain a high degree of toxins
in its system and a high degree of fat
no matter what you feed it so according
to the Bible you want to stay away from
pork it's an unclean animal yes all
right and Anthony from Michigan welcome
to Bible answers live here on the air
hey um my question is my father he used
to encourage me to try to take god
seriously but now he himself doesn't
want anything to do with God
and my mother
I'm not trying to judge but she seems to
take it a little bit lightly and I want
to honor my father and mother so that I
can keep both the Ten Commandments but I
don't know if until I see them taken a
relationship with God more seriously
would my efforts be better spent trying
to please God in other ways well you
know I think a good question I think
first of all we want to try and honor
our parents irrespective of whether or
not they follow God I mean just the fact
that there are parents we want to treat
them with respect but having said that
is you know God is our first parent and
he needs to be first and foremost in our
life we don't want to do those things to
honor our parents that would contradict
honoring our heavenly father so you know
that's the priority but what can we do
for our parents if that if they're not
serious about taking uh their
Christianity or trusting in God we can
pray for them we can be an example in
the way we live uh we can't keep
harassing them we need to respect them
and and let them make their own decision
or we can pray for them try and be a
good example and when the opportunity
opens up we could witness but we can't
push our views on anyone but we can't
pray for them at the same time do
everything you can to witness to others
it's not one or the other it's both in
everything we do we try to be a positive
example to to others and you know Pat
Carlos I know you were a opportunity to
witness to your parents and you actually
had the privilege of of baptizing your
mom and Anthony and your dad so uh just
through your example and not pushing but
being able to be a positive light you're
able to make an impact upon the
alignment let them see Christ in you
that's right well friends we're coming
up on our end of the program for those
who are listening on satellite radio for
the rest of you stand by we're going to
take your email questions
foreign
to today's broadcast we hope you
understand your Bible even better than
before Bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts International a
faith-based Ministry located in Granite
Bay California
[Music]
all right we want to welcome you back to
this special bonus part that we have
with email questions that have come in
and so we'll do a rapid fire email
questions for Pastor John John God
created everything in the universe but
who created God oh that's the question
we hit quite a bit where did God come
from the Bible doesn't tell us matter of
fact the Bible says that God's ways is
higher than our ways the Bible says God
is eternal he has no beginning he has no
end we can't understand that we live in
a realm of time we have a beginning we
have an end everything we know has a
beginning and an end but God is not in
our realm the Bible says he's Eternal so
those are the questions we'll probably
need to ask when we get to heaven but
the Bible doesn't tell us all right
Lindsay Inlet is asking is Zechariah in
the Old Testament the author of the book
Zechariah the father of John the Baptist
no there are two different people
Zechariah was a a popular name or at
least a more common Jewish name
Zachariah the father of John the Baptist
is not the same Zechariah that wrote the
book of Zechariah in the Old Testament
all right another question God demanded
the Israelites to annihilate the
occupants of pagan cities but what will
be the fate of the children and babies
of those cities at the resurrection
yes what happens to those who died under
the age of accountability in these
judgments that came I guess the same
question he asked with reference to the
children at the time of the flood when
God destroyed the flood there were
children young children little babies
well I think God's gonna have to deal
with those individually as far as
judgment he knows the end from the
beginning what we do know is for a
Believer if they lose their child they
have the hope of being reunited with
their child in the resurrection so for a
Believer if a child dies under the age
of accountability or a baby we have the
hope of being reunited all right another
question either 144 000 the only people
saved when Jesus comes well the Bible
speaks about a group of people that will
be saved when Jesus comes we have the
Seal of God in their foreheads it also
talks about a great Resurrection where
people will be from every multitude
Nation tribe and tongue and people there
will be a great group of people so the
144 000 represent God's end time
Apostles you might say who are in a
special way doing a work for proclaiming
the Three Angels messages at the end of
time they symbolize those who will be
translated when Jesus comes a second
time all right what did Jesus mean when
he said that night is coming when no one
can work
well you know now is the opportunity
that we can work there is a Time coming
the Bible says in revelation 22 where
Jesus says he that is Holy let me be
holy still he that is filthy let him be
filthy still probation closes it's too
late then now is the time for us to work
well friends you hear the sound of the
music we are running out of time but
until next week God bless
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]